[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kabhi HD here
and I'm a person who uses a lot of
technology that's why we review it I use
a lot of tech and being a user first it
will gives me a pretty good perspective
of a lot of stuff and I did like a video
like this maybe four ish years ago where
I'm talking to Apple about a whole bunch
of stuff that I'd like them to do I
think it's time to have a bit of a sit
down and chat with the 2017 version of
this most powerful consumer electronics
company in the world dear Apple you
should matte-black all the thing or at
least give the option like I know the
trademarked white table and white
earpods and white mouse they don't have
to go anywhere but I'd be curious does
the space gray MacBook sell more than
the other color do you think people
would buy or maybe even pay a little bit
extra for a matte black version if you
offered it you kind of got it started
with a matte black version of the iPhone
7 which in my opinion is the best
colorway of any iPhone ever I really do
think that I have no idea what sales
numbers look like and I don't even know
if you tell anyone which color sells the
most but I'd be willing to bet that
people really like them that black
imagine a matte black Mac Pro imagine a
matte black iMac or a matte black Apple
keyboard or Apple trackpad and matte
black Apple accessories it would be so
sweet to see them go matte black with
all the same imagine matte black air pod
I mean they already are pretty easy to
lose so that might not get any better
but I feel like they would look a little
bit less ridiculous in the ear color
we're a company I've talked about before
who like just paint stuff they do custom
paint jobs they are offering now air
pods just painted black or painted any
other color and there was actually even
a company just started called black pods
specifically just to sell matte black
air pods so uh maybe Apple take a hint
and start offering that colorway dear
Apple USB type-c all the things now hear
me out you're already well on your way
to doing this you are already right up
at the front of the USBC line with your
one port wonder 12-inch MacBook it was a
little bit user hostile at the time but
we get the idea now the new MacBook Pros
are still all USB type-c all the time
that's still pushing it but at least we
have you know adapters to be able to
cross that
Bridge to the future so while you're at
it maybe USB type-c that iPhone though I
know Apple makes a ton of money from
lightning I get that they can license it
and I even know that lightning is
actually physically I think a smaller
port than USB type-c but for all that
being said Apple users have never known
the feeling of coming home with one
charger and being able to charge up your
laptop and your phone with the same
cable USB C is the standard for a bunch
of reasons the data throughput the power
throughput the universal nature of USB I
know it's not going to be the favorite
thing to do especially because there are
so many lightning accessories already
but it just feels like obviously USB
type-c is the future moving forward on a
bunch of different platforms and hey if
we can use adapters to get our Mac books
and our laptops to the future and we can
do our phones too right
I mean you guys are the ones to take
away the headphone jack so you're pretty
familiar with that you got dear Apple
please refresh the Mac Pro please okay
so this is admittedly a much more niche
product that almost no one buys and no
one cares about and that's why Apple
hardly focuses on the pro market anymore
there's just no one buying you there's
no volume well your Apple so you have
the power if you wanted to to hire
literally a special team of people
engineers designers and just put them in
a room for a couple months just to come
up with the next-gen the ideal the
perfect Mac Pro and the pros would love
you for it I know it's not big I know
there's only like 12 of us Final Cut Pro
Mac Pro editors left on the planet I get
that but we're so hungry for an updated
crazy I've been a Final Cut Pro editor
for the past couple years I switched
from a PC and Premiere and so I have to
use the most powerful Mac that Apple
makes to do my work which is at this
point this the Mac Pro the four year old
12 chord trash can Mac Pro it's kind of
a joke at this point normally a 4 year
old computer isn't that old but the fact
that this is the most powerful most
advanced machine that Apple makes is
pretty sad and they still sell it for
the same price that they did when it
launched which is even more sense after
those who are already typing oh just
just build a powerful PC and switch back
to Premiere well first is the Mac Pro
even in its current state still with
Final Cut Pro renders and exports and
plays back videos faster than the more
powerful piece
use that I've tried and second of all
there are plenty of great plugins for
Final Cut Pro that just don't exist in
the Adobe ecosystem that I use all the
time so I won't be switching back
anytime soon
just for performance but that doesn't
mean I can't complain a little bit have
you seen like the fan made mock-ups of
the 2017 Mac Pro with like a full
desktop GPU and Thunderbolt 3 USB type-c
all that stuff I'll try to link it below
if I can find it I'm just saying I'd get
it I get it dear Apple you got to get
wireless charging in the next iPhone I
was going to say bring the headphone
jack back but I feel like we know that's
not going to happen so if Apple's really
on our way to a completely portlets
iPhone no headphone jack no ports at all
you do have to eventually get rid of
that charging port if you do if you just
skip USB type-c you got to get people
used to wireless charging so whether
it's the iPhone 7s or the iPhone 8 or
the iPhone X or the 10th anniversary
whatever they call it I feel like that
could be the killer feature of the next
iPhone and we've seen Apple tend to sort
of stay back on new technologies and
wait for them to develop and then it
adopts them late and do them better and
I feel like that could be an opportunity
to do that with wireless charging this
is probably like the fourth individual
video where I've said that they should
have wireless charging in the iPhone but
now you know how it feels to have it
just a couple things I wanted to get off
my chest just don't feel like it's a
refreshed list of things that we want to
see from a company in 2017 who can
totally do these things that they want
to it's just a matter of whether they
want to or not maybe we've a comment
below which one of these you'd like to
see the most
I know USB type-c is pretty high on my
list but I also just like matte black so
much it's hard to go wrong with it
anyway that's pretty much it thank you
for watching
talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]